think of your favorite Marvel heroes
maybe you love spider-man one of the
most iconic and well-known heroes to
ever grace the silver screen maybe
you're a huge fan of Iron Man or you
realized after Ragnarok that four was
your favorite like me maybe you prefer
villains and you love big baddie Thanos
or even the charming kill monger
so it's impossible these days to ignore
these characters they're everywhere they
make billions of dollars and many are
household names but not so long ago the
future of Marvel and its heroes hung in
the balance
in fact the MCU may have never existed
without a certain pack vampire
half-human black superhero yes I am
talking about blade the daywalker
every vampire's worst nightmare and star
of the first successful movie that
Marvel ever made it's entirely possible
that like me you didn't even realize he
was a Marvel character the r-rated
feature was dark gritty stylish and a
ton of fun it's a find lead actor Wesley
Snipes career blade went from being a
relatively unknown Marvel c-lister to
surprising everyone when he made 131
million dollars at the box office on
just a 45 million dollar budget the
movie spawned a trilogy that went on to
earn a combined 415 million dollars it
couldn't have come at a better time for
Marvel and in many ways it saved
Marvel's cinema prospects entirely as
well as revived the superhero genre to
understand why it was so impactful we
need to go back to the beginning of
superhero movies superhero adaptations
first started in the 1940s as serials
but didn't start making waves on the
silver screen until the 70s and 80s when
Marvel's rival DC Comics achieved early
critical success with Superman in 1978
Superman - in 1981 and Batman in 1989
the superhero genre is in a bad place DC
had a string of misfires with 1997's
Batman and Robin nearly killing the
genre entirely
Marvel made a Fantastic Four movie that
was never released and that's probably
for the best in fact the only movie
Marvel did release up to this point was
1986 is Howard the Duck a big-budget
flop targeted toward children I have
absolutely no idea why this movie was
made it was also in the 90s that the
comic bubble burst the market was
oversaturated publishers were putting
out hundreds of new issues most of which
were embarrassingly bad they also cost
more than double in 1993 than what they
used to in 1985 the public at large just
didn't want to pick up expensive bad
comics interest in the genre winged
things were looking pretty grim
especially for Marvel so how did it
manage to turn things around in 1993
Marvel assumed partial ownership of toy
bits which would receive exclusive
rights to producing Marvel toys that's
when toy biz designer avi arad
came in to guide Marvel films the
company's restructured film studio he
was ambitious and most importantly saw
the potential in superhero films by the
end of 1993 he licensed the x-men out to
20th Century Fox
but despite a-rod's best efforts Marvel
declared bankruptcy on December 27 1996
years of bad investments and bad
decisions coupled with the big hit from
the comic bubble burst finally caught up
to the company but Arad refused to give
up on the potential of marvel's
characters even being quoted as saying
spider-man alone is worth a billion
dollars
he wasn't wrong having rebranded Marvel
films as Marvel Studios just before
bankruptcy Marvel trudged onward
investing money in feature film
production bankruptcy paid off Marvel's
debts but that wasn't enough to survive
for years the company had been licensing
out characters to other studios for
quick cash it was high time to get those
films made and make Marvel a big name in
Hollywood the studio turned its
attention to a relatively unknown
character whose film development had
been in limbo at new line since 1992
there were stings out tonight than
vampires I quite like me blade was the
first film packaged and licensed by
Marvel Studios it was its first modern
movie that in itself is incredibly
significant handling the script was
burgeoning screenwriter David s Goyer
who would go on to write Christopher
Nolan's critically lauded Dark Knight
trilogy new line brought Gore in to
adept blade into a campy vampire hunting
movie but the young writer had different
plans he wanted to take blade seriously
starring as blade was of course Wesley
Snipes there probably hasn't been a more
pitched perfect superhero casting ever
except for maybe Robert Downey jr. as
Iron Man
Snipes lent an absolutely undeniable
level of cool to the character he took
the character so seriously that you had
no choice but to as well
not to mention the fact that Snipes
himself is an incredible martial artist
who choreographed all of the film's
fight scenes Boyer and director Stephen
Norrington made the decision to age up
the film to appeal to adult comic fans
this wasn't a cute movie it hit hard it
was seedy grimy gory and most
importantly grounded in a way that no
superhero film had been before meanwhile
they efficiently established the inner
workings of blades world in which a
hidden Society of vampires pull all the
strings from behind the scenes it's a
rich world parallel to ours similar
enough to remind us of the world we
inhabit but full of otherworldly
concepts in which the audience could
lose itself it was this kind of world
building that would lend a significant
amount of relatability to films like The
Dark Knight and The Avengers that world
soon unveils an impressive roster of
incredible supporting characters from
blades grizzled mentor Whistler played
by Kris Kristofferson to Stephen Dorff
slide Deacon Frost a villainous vampire
looking to upend the ancient vampire
establishment and eliminate blade to dr.
Karen Jenson a courageous hematologist
portrayed by anna Boucher writes who
saves blades life multiple times
throughout the film and had so many
things going for it so many pieces
perfectly shifting into place when
opened on August 21st 1998 it made 131
million dollars globally though it
wasn't exactly critically acclaimed it
quickly became a cult classic it was an
O moment for Marvel the studio had
finally scored its first hit here's the
thing
Marvel only made about 25 thousand
dollars off of Blades box office returns
so it would be entirely incorrect to say
that the daywalker saved the company
financially instead blade was more of a
moral victory for Marvel finally
establishing it as a rising force in
Hollywood it demonstrated that audiences
could be drawn towards Marvel's c-list
characters just imagine what could
happen if Marvel made a movie about an
a-lister in 1999
one year after blades release Marvel
sold the rights for spider-man to Sony a
year after that in 2000 x-men made its
way out of development purgatory it made
almost 300 million dollars at the
international box office in 2000 but
perhaps without the success of blade it
would have remained in limbo for longer
or forever in 2002 spider-man
starring Tobey Maguire and directed by
Sam Raimi was released to critical
acclaim and even larger box office
numbers over 800 million Marvel was
witnessing a stark upward trend and it
all began with Blade but still Marvel
wasn't exactly profiting off of the
successes of these films $25,000 from
blade nothing from x-men due to a flat
fee negotiation and only about 62
million from the first two spider-man
movies a decent chunk of money but it
was chump change when you considered
those two movies made over three billion
dollars in 2003 a talent agent named
David Maisel flew to Florida to have
lunch with a Marvel executive and he
pitched a relatively simple but
ground-shaking idea make the movies
yourself and retain 100% of the profits
it was a few years later that the Marvel
Studios we know and love today began to
operate in earnest as an in-house
production studio when Iron Man was
released in 2008 it was a smashing
success making about 600 million dollars
globally after decades of bad decisions
bad luck and finally a stroke of success
starting with blade the door to the MCU
finally opened so aside from being
Marvel's first successful film how do we
qualify blades legacy on the MCU and the
superhero genre the most obvious example
is probably in blades world building
which we've already highlighted in this
video four blade gore dreamt up a
compelling and at times totally bonkers
world that ran parallel to ours nearly
every film in the MCU even the most
literal spaced-out ones like guardians
of the galaxy relied on this approach to
deliver a sense of relatability to the
audience you're from Earth Missouri
yeah that's on earth Duke even x-men
which followed blade and is often
considered to be the film that ushered
in the modern era of superhero movies
took that page at a blades book blade
also showed more generally that comics
told genuinely great stories and that if
approached with some degree of
relatability a film about a vampire
slaying half vampire could absolutely
function as a summer blockbuster in
terms of casting blade was revolutionary
in that blade himself was tailored to
fit Snipes persona and strengths not the
other way around
in fact when blade himself debuted in
1973 in tomb of Dracula number 10
his original character was a far cry
from the one portrayed in the film
Wesley Snipes is blade much in the same
way that Robert Downey jr. is Iron Man
the way that writers approach both
characters has forever been changed by
the way both actors molded the character
around themselves and we would be remiss
to overlook blades role and
representation on screen for black
actors when Black Panther was released
in 2018 it was lauded rightfully so for
its nearly all black cast and crew but
many were quick to point out that this
was not the first successful black led
superhero film with Snipes and blade
changing the game as the first
financially successful superhero film
with the black lead 20 years prior and
again we cannot overlook the fact that
dr. Karen Jensen was not exactly a love
interest for blade but an independent
black woman who saved blade from certain
death
multiple times she may be even more so
than blade was ahead of her time blade
also proved long before Deadpool that
r-rated comic book movies can make
serious Bank at the box office
fun fact Ryan Reynolds plays a
significant role in blade Trinity but
apparently didn't get along with Snipes
or rather blade onset
having been quoted as saying I've never
met Wesley Snipes I've only met blade
who wouldn't want to meet blade I would
while I was making this video it
occurred to me that Marvel's entire film
catalog could be thought of as a house
imagine a house think of all of Marvel's
movies as a part of the house all houses
need walls and a roof those can be x-men
and spider-man respectively perhaps the
door to the house is Iron Man inside the
house the first Avengers movie is the
pricey couch and chair set the guardians
of the galaxy is the weird base on the
mantle the basement is full of weird
things like the second Thor movie and
Avengers age of Ultron the sleek new
Lexus in the garage is black panther but
every house begins with the foundation
that foundation is blade it's not the
first thing people notice about a house
most people wouldn't notice it at all
but it's there doing its job making sure
the walls don't fall that the roof stays
attached and all of your pretty things
inside stay safe take away the
foundation and the whole structure falls
without the foundation established by
blade it is entirely possible that
Marvel may have never found its footing
or the guts it needed to turn its
bankruptcy into billions so what do you
think do you agree with me or not do you
want to see blade slices way into the
MCU let us know in the comments below